[Musique]
je m'appelle Léonard
contente de rencontrer Gwen
pourquoi vous êtes là sûrement pour être
ami avec toi et
je suis très très triste pourquoi
à cause de ce que je dois faire
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
il y a une femme qui tient un truc ça
ressemble à une pioche avec une chaîne
Hermès
tous les quatre on a une mission
importante
c'est peut-être à la mission la plus
de l'histoire du monde
nous avons été appelés et sommesunis par
une vision commune qui maintenant
s'impose à nous comme un ordre que nous
pouvons ignorer
[Musique]
nous sommes ici tous les quatre
pour empêcher l'Apocalypse
votre famille a été élu pour faire un
choix épouvantable
vous n'y parvenez pas
ce sera la fin du monde
[Musique]